that is right for me it's a right thing
to do for me as Chief Constable to
clearly State the institutional racism
sexism misogyny and discrimination exist
please Scotland is institutionally
racist and discriminatory
publicly acknowledging these
institutional issues exist in our
organization is essential to our
absolutely commit our absolute
commitment championing equality and
becoming an anti-racist service
it is also critical
to our determination
to lead wider change and support wider
change in society
Prejudice and bad behavior within
Precinct highlighted by court and
conduct cases various independent
reviews and by listening to our own
officers and staff over recent years is
rightly of great concern utterly
condemned there's no place in police
Scotland for those who reject our values
and standards our vigilance as an
organization has never been stronger
rigorous recruitment enhanced vetting
more visible conduct outcomes and a
focus on prevention